yes there is something i want to ask you  all right how the [ __ ] do you write so  many books so fast  i've had a really good six months i've  written three chapters and you've you've  had three books in that time  the way that that the way that i work uh  i try to get out there and i try to get  six pages a day so with a book like end  of watch and i work when i'm working i  work every day  uh three four hours and i try to get  those six pages and i try to get them  fairly clean so if the manuscript is  let's say  360 pages long that's basically two  months work it's concentrated but it's a  fairly  but that's assuming that it goes well  and you do hit six pages a day i usually  do you don't ever have a day where you  sit down there and it's like  constipation and you write a sentence  and you hate the sentence and okay  you check your email and you wonder if  you had any talent after all and